make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
late to the game okay uh we are covering
venom Volume one we are so late to this
we're covering venom Volume one I'm
calling this the god butcher send me it
one because its clickbait and two it
sounds cooler and three because it's
true so then um bye Donnie Cates is
ridiculously good right like it's one of
the it's one of the the coolest things
is it's the best thing coming out of
Marvel legacy right now which isn't hard
to do so with regards to this whole
thing this again really kind of focus on
Eddie Brock but as this is cool
it's an expansion of the venom mythos
but it's not a retcon for those guys who
are new to comics here's one thing comic
book fans hate when a writer creates
something cool like for all the people
who say they hate Brian Michael Bendis
it's kind of ironic because like they
like this stuff he does which is kind of
cool they're like I hate Brian Michael
Bendis but only under certain
circumstances right it's like who Brian
Michael Bendis it like a wholesale
revitalization of like the venom mythos
when it came to like the symbionts the
only kind of stuff and guardians of the
galaxy during the planning of the
planets envyus Toyland what Donnie Cates
does here is he ties into Jason Aaron's
run on Ford he ties into Brian Michael
Bendis is planet symbiote story and
Gardens the galaxy and then he ties into
the existing venom mythos and then
actually like sort of brings all those
things together and then expands on it
at the same time which is something
that's very hard to do and that's kind
of you and that's how you kind of know
that like Donnie Cates is like a comic
book reader right because you have cover
you have people who write comics and
don't really read them all that often
and then you have people who like have
just read comics for a long time and
then write into it which works
exceedingly well the ones who do their
research and so what this does is this
initially kind of picks up with Eddie
Brock getting like these flashes to like
a time before he existed when like some
kind of venom Stimme it was like
attacking things and and tearing up like
this Norwegian town and all I kind of
got stuff for their Holland for Beowulf
and whatnot who actually did exist in
Marvel Comics up but these are
flashbacks to a life that Eddie Brock
never lived now when assembiy it Bond's
itself to a host and then leaves that
host and bonds itself to someone else
the memories of the original host come
along with it and so basically what
Eddie Brock is doing is having
flashbacks to either what are his
original memories from the Venom
symbiote or all the memories of
something else and this is what Donnie
Cates kind of expands on when it comes
to the simian mythos and again we'll
talk more about that here in a second
but what's going on is it at the moment
the venoms to me it's kind of losing its
mind right legis is reverting into like
a psychopathic state and then regaining
itself so it's really just kind of like
going absolutely bonkers
going insane the way this plays out is
when Eddie Brock basically tracked down
the new jack-o'-lantern another new
jack-o'-lantern is a pop Whittier he's
not really important it is kind of
serves to progress the story and the
reason why is because when Eddie tracks
that version of jackal this this new
version of jack-o'-lantern down the
symbiotes goes crazy and then tries to
kill jack-o'-lantern so that's when
Eddie Brock really kind of regains
control when he's attacked by the cops
and it sort of regains his bearings you
know when explosion goes off and
everything and we end up finding out
that all this has kind of been set up by
Rex Strickland now Rex Strickland is a
wholly new character created by Donnie
Cates he's really kind of brought in
here this is his first appearance and
whatwhat's really kind of given right
off the bat is that he's a guy that
basically knows his way around symbionts
and so what's kind of going on here is
Rex Strickland really sits down with
Eddie Brock and says you believe that
you're the only person to wield a venom
Simien on earth besides Peter Parker
besides spider-man but that's not true
instead what happened was somewhere
along the line shield got their hands on
venom symbiotes and then bonded them to
soldiers and use them for the purpose of
implementing campaigns and so shield got
their hands on him they basically bonded
them to soldiers or I guess people who
were former soldiers were essentially on
their deathbeds and then they were just
kind of sent out into the world and so
what's cool about this is that this guy
Rex Strickland basically says his former
teammates had basically gone insane
because of their symbionts now again
this is kind of injury intriguing here
because one of the things that was sort
of touched on early on in the days of
spider-man and then actually kind of
confirmed during a what-if comic is that
if a semi had stayed bonded to a host
for too long it would drive them insane
and then consume them as a rush
Strickland's idea is his teammates who
have basically been bonded to the Venom
symbiote and then basically went insane
are being taken to like one of these
black ops sites by shield and they're
gonna be eliminated and presumably the
the venom Samir's are gonna be taken
examined or what have you but what are
basically the Friends of Rex Strickland
are gonna be killed off the problem is
that they're essentially insane and so
Rex Strickland is hit up venom for the
purpose of saying you're the only guy
who can track these guys down so when
that happens and venom finally does that
the problem is that once these guys
emerge they basically kind of wake up
this quote-unquote symbiote God not
really understanding what it is but
speaking this kind of crazy language
that the crazy Venom symbiote speaks
whenever it seems to go awry so again a
lot of cloak-and-dagger going on and
this first little issue here but when
the whole thing comes to a close meta to
say these guys basically escape they
wake up this force that's up there this
force strips them of their symbionts and
then emerges is like a giant bat kind of
thing and so it's sort of cool here
because you know initially like
immediately what happens is you
literally have at the Venom symbiote
kind of fixing any brach from the
various pieces of damage that he
suffered and then trying to track down
or at least going back to Rex trickling
and basically saying give us the whole
picture tell us what's really going on
here and so what's what Rex essentially
says is that again kind of reheating on
this whole thing about shield and about
the idea of like the venom simmias being
bonded to him that what his symbiote was
bonded to him what he got was kind of
this recollection of everything that had
happened in the universe since it's very
beginning all the way up to the present
day and everything the Simeon had been
doing and so again it can really go one
of two ways and again we'll find out
what direction Donnie Cates is going on
here but it can go one of two ways
either the Simeon of wreck Strickland is
getting memories to an event it wasn't
part of meaning is getting the memories
of other symbionts or the simia that
belonged to wreck Strickland really had
just been around that long and it
basically which has all these
recollections from everything this
semitte had ever done as it was kind of
cool here because it's basically
expanding on this whole great big huge
set of events and so again like with
with venom showing up alongside Miles
Morales and fighting this giant symbiote
dragon that kind of exists out there
there's not a whole lot going on here I
mean there is a little bit insofar as
what miles does with regards to the fact
that he has that them or that that venom
shock which again is basically just like
an electrical shock um where were it
manages to quote-unquote damage any rock
to a degree any kind of wakes up to the
idea of saying if the the venom shock of
spider-man of Miles works against me
then if he can basically amp it up if he
can juice it up use it to it in its max
capacity he could presumably take this
thing out and that's exactly what what
miles does the two of them kind of
orchestrate a plan they pull a little
bit of a fastball special and literally
like land miles in the mouth of this
giant monster thing when it goes to
attack him and he uses of course his his
venom shock blows it up only for us to
realize that what is kind of done is
reconstituted this being of sorts and
this is cool because when this being
shows up it's literally like you're
outmatched and you guys don't have a
chance and it's kind of a cool thing and
the reason why is because what this guy
does of course once he reveals his name
is being null what he does is seize
control the symbian of Eddie Brock like
he literally strips the symbian off of
Eddie and says come to me and do as I
tell you to and it's kind of crazy
because it it creates this kind of field
around the two of them around like
around spider-man and around Eddie
around the simian in itself and then
basically kind of goes on this this sort
of discussion
what does symbiote proper and this is
kind of cool because what happens here
is Donnie Cates writes this is such a
way to where no kind of presents himself
as this
that's well aware of what the Symbian is
that knows everything about the Symbian
and even identifies too in such a way as
saying you've been corrupted by humanity
now this is where Donnie Keith starts to
tie in to the to the idea of Brian
Michael Bendis this is where he starts a
tie into what Bendis did with a planet
of this simian storyline so again not
wiping all that away because while
Bendis is really kind of being looked at
at least it seems being looked at by
Marvel is kind of hey you went to the
competition you're a bad guy now and
they're systematically sort of wiping
away everything Bendis did the fact that
Donnie Cates throws us into the venom
story means now it's here to stay but
the way that the way that this kind of
goes down is null basically grabs Eddie
Brock and then sort of shows him the
history of himself and this is this is
cool because we get basically Jason
Aaron's God butchers storyline all
thrown in with Brian Michael Bendis
storyline this sort of ties into the
origin of the universe but when it came
to null himself he's the result of the
destruction of a previous universe and
the creation of a new one now we're not
told explicitly how the way it seems to
kind of play out is some time between
the death of the old universe and the
beginning of whatever this new one
happens to be that null came into
existence we don't really know how but
he existed in this empty void that
became the formation of a new universe
and so when the Celestials started
creating stars and planets and solar
systems and galaxies and different
things like that they were filling up a
void that house null with all kinds of
life and so basically nolo Cup and war
between them broke out the issue with
this is that null didn't really
seemingly know how to defeat his
celestial right off the bat him he did
to a degree in the sense that he
fashioned a sword and then basically
killed him or chopped off the head of
one of them but following that and
following his defeat where he was cast
back into the void again again kind of
hinting at the idea that he or he or
originates from outside of this universe
somewhere out in the multiverse that
what null did is he fashioned what was
called the all-black necro sword now
this is where we start tying into Jason
Aaron's Thor because for those of you
guys who read god butcher we didn't know
where the oh where the all-black necro
sword came from what donnie case is
doing here is kind of providing the back
end of that and saying that when null
had essentially face off and decapitated
one of the Celestials and was banished
by the rest of them he created the
all-black necro sword and then went on a
campaign literally fighting every God
that he came across and just inflicting
death and destruction everywhere he
could and when that happened he
ultimately came across one being the two
of them fought each other and when they
when they effectively kill each other
they landed on the planet that that
belonged to gore and gore discovering
their bodies picked up the all-black
necro sword not really
as capable of so again it's cool because
what this does is kind of tie in it
really sort of ties together a lot of
these little plot points that I kind of
been floating out there in Marvel Comics
with regards to other people's work and
so following this what ended up
happening with null is it he basically
sort of RIA what on this planet that we
that he was on but realized he could
bond his life essence to other beings
essentially becoming the first the first
Symbian and when that happened he
basically began to sort of corral all
these different concepts that existed
out there you know sort of creating
simmias or creating a kind of hive mind
and then literally saw all of them from
across the the universe so through a
kind of seat of power he could watch the
universe and watch how if simius were
interacting with other races and other
beings that went out there and then
essentially just kind of like control
them in and of himself and so what ended
up happening is that when he arrived on
earth that his connection to all these
symbionts that existed out there was
disrupted when he fought Thor and Thor
literally using the power of lightning
is one of the weaknesses of the
symbiotes kind of cut off the connection
between no and and these various simius
that existed across the universe and so
again because all this happened
presumably billions of years ago
countless years ago what this does is it
back ends to Brian Michael Bendis his
plan of the symbiotes and it says that
following the defeat of Nall in the
planets imbiah storyline that was
created by Bendis all these symbionts
took up residence on a singular planet
now the way that no kind of plays this
off is we view it as a planet but really
it's just a gathering of the largest
horde of symbionts in reality there are
other simmias that exist in other places
across the across the entirety of the
universe but the brunt of them exists on
that singular planet and so we kind of
have to assume the way they've been
destroyed sit and the way that that
Donnie Cates writes this we can kind of
combine the two of them together and say
well from those perspective the
symbiotes really just kind of gathered
in a singular place but the way that
bindus writes it the simians kind of
came together and formed a sort of a
role that they played where they
basically became kind of Knights of the
universe which is to say that what they
would do is they would bond themselves
to a singular host and when that
happened that host would become a kind
of savior of the universe or at least a
section of the universe akin to like the
Green Lantern's from DC but a symbiote
could be corrupted by a singular being
the way the Donnie Cates writes this is
he kind of says that's not really the
case instead what happens is the
inherent nature of a symbiote is to be
dark it is to be evil because that's
what it originates from and so we're
buiness would say these symbiotes can
bond themselves and much like the venom
version on earth basically became
corrupted by Eddie Brock but
actually happen is the Venom symbiote
touched the lights so to speak touched a
good guy and became a good guy when it
bonded itself to Peter Parker so
basically it betrayed his nature when it
joined Peter Parker and became a good
guy and then when it left Peter in Joe
and Eddie it reverted back to its normal
nature and became a bad guy that's way
back in the early days along the way the
venomous simian has started to become a
good guy again
and so it's kind of it's kind of cool
because what it does is it takes the
entire concept of venom as we know it
and flips it on its head instead of
believing the Venom symbiote is
inherently a good guy who became a bad
guy because of venom and then became a
good guy again which was this normal
part than instead the Venom symbiote was
always a bad guy and then it became a
good guy with Peter it went back to his
normal nature with Eddie and then it's
been working its way to try to become a
good guy ever since it's been betraying
its nature this entire ton as that's
kind of the cool thing here it works
exceedingly well and so what this does
is it hits home with the idea that with
no basically returning what he's done is
restore his connection to the to the
various simius that exist out there and
then intends to kind of go on a conquest
and sort of go ballistic and so on and
so forth but what it's been doing it is
really kind of saying okay this null as
we see him now is actually just a
Symbian the actual null exists out there
on a planet somewhere and is just kind
of waiting to be reborn in order to
return itself but in order for a null to
actually return for the actual null to
come back what it needs is it needs like
a fifth missing piece basically saying
that like the other four soldiers the
other four semi isn't it absorbed when
it first popped up as a giant bat
looking thing that's four out of five
pieces of a puzzle
it needs a fifth piece and then null
himself will actually return and when
that happens the indication is the
universe could presumably be doomed
because of the massive amount of power
that no possesses and so it's kind of
cool here because basically with this
whole thing
unfolding they you know kind of going
down the way that it is this leads to
Venom symbiote telling Eddie Brock
because of the fact that we've
encountered this null symbian what it
means is that now we have a host of
power so it's kind of a way for for
decades to introduce new abilities to
venom I just sort of saying hey this
part of the simian has been unlocked you
know more or less but when venom when
Eddie Brock sits down and starts a thing
about everything that's been going on
what he does is realize not everything
is what it seems especially if like the
fifth piece of this Grendel basically
this this kind of missing pieces have to
all be brought back together the fifth
one is here for a reason because like
Noah's looking for it and so what he
ends up doing is traveling back to Rex
Strickland and basically saying give me
the whole story
and that's what we find out this is not
actually right
Stricklen instead this is the Symbian of
Rex Strickland there's somewhere along
the line Rex tricking himself had
basically died that when the semi had
bonded to Rex and it basically became a
good guy and much the same way that the
symbiote did when it bonded to Flash
Thompson originally and then is now kind
of back to Eddie Brock that is basically
a good guy here that because Rex had
died the symbiote kind of continued on
in his image and so this symbiote is it
was originally part of the whole part of
the the Horde of null and in order for a
knoll to come back this simian is kinda
like the last missing piece that needs
to be bonded with with the null SIM be
had in order to in order for that no
semi to travel back to the home planet
of the symbiotes and then for an old
finally rise and so that's when they
sort of bond together when when Eddie
says the only way for you to truly be
safe is to bond yourself to me and when
that happens everything will be fine
like everything will be okay and so with
the two of them basically bonding
together and working together as a
singular unit they look pretty awesome
they look pretty badass but it's
basically Eddie with all the new powers
he got from you know from touching milk
along with all the existing powers he
got from the Rex Strickland Symbian so
again it's pretty awesome here
especially kind of combining all these
different abilities together the problem
with this is that with them facing off
against this null version of the Symbian
it's wildly powerful I guess it's
extremely capable and not easily
destroyed and so any showing up here is
kind of like okay look we can't really
defeat it in and of ourselves like if
the most worst stopgap measured because
what does Nolan again.what null does is
kind of try to tap into the simian of
Rex and the venom version and it
actually cannot control it and so
because it cannot control them the
response is well then I'll just kill the
host and I'll take them forcefully and
so again trying to kill Eddie it's Eddie
basically like blasting and was like
sonic bomb sonic grenades or so on and
so forth and then it kind of begins to
wrap up relatively fast in so far that
what is up happening as a venom Samiha
basically says the only way for you to
really win is to use the one absolute
weakness which is fired and so in this
instance Eddie grabs null and it's kind
of like forces him into like this
furnace basically you know and we're
know what kind of tries to latch on and
tries to get out and so on and so forth
it's literally burning the Venom
symbiote and then burning null along
with the rest strickland symbian kind of
burning them all at the same time and so
we're where Eddie himself is actually on
fire and not really looking to like
sacrifice or losses on Simeon in the
process the Simeon in turn bonds to
Eddie because you know where the stimuli
jumps off like oh my god is fire I gotta
go Eddie says no you have to come back
you have to keep me alive here in order
to make sure that like null dies
basically asking the venom soviet to
sack
fights itself and that's exactly what
happens the Venom symbiote rebounds
itself to Eddie keeps him alive long
enough to keep the door closed and then
in turn while he's laying there the
Venom symbiote basically seems to have
been killed it seems to have been
eliminated by the fact that Eddie can't
really hear it anymore so again it's a
cool story I'm surprised it took me so
long to cover this thing
Donny Cates Donny Donny Cates okay so
his his venom Samiha venom run there's
amazing it is absolutely amazing without
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here two
comments explained make sure you guys
have a sub button to become part of the
robb core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later purse
[Music]
you